[Applause]
another singing celebrity revealed on
the masked singer this is so stressful I
gotta thank y'all for voting me off this
it's been so much fun
what is more difficult playing football
or doing this
oh this by far is event TV again you're
tuning in at the time it airs so you can
talk about it have conversations on
Twitter about it like it's it's funny
getting to have event TV and prime time
again is really exciting
the competition is well underway Terry
is the third singing celebrity in
disguise to get the boot first was NFL
star Antonio Brown then comedy legend
Tommy Chong there's some stories that
are emotional some get more emotional
some get more fun and you can see the
difference between the people who are
taking this very seriously this is a
passion this is something that they
always wanted to do overcome a fear show
the world that they they're different in
this space and there's something like
what are you doing there like we all
knew that Tommy Chong was gay was high
all get-out I would dress up like a
pineapple you knew that that was gonna
be fun et was with the panelists and
host Nick Cannon ahead of the series
premiere to figure out how they keep
things so hush-hush when they're on set
talk about how secret the identities are
brightly the producers are just so I
know nothing you know nothing and even
when I like they like try to ban us from
talking to each other because they don't
want us to guess so like we're not even
that allowed to talk about who we think
but do you really not know I don't know
I know I'm like I'm trying to guess just
like everyone else and like it's funny
because I'm standing next to them and
some of them right looking at their neck
like yeah that's it that's all that's a
young neck that's a yeah that Nick can't
be over 35 I know that Nick you know I'm
like trying to figure it out but other
than that they like keep them in caves
or a layer under the studio or somewhere
you have their agents put on masks you
sky's them on the way here Nicholas two
words you describe it
bonkers
[Applause]